a
destruction du monument exacerbe
les tensions.
Tamara Altéresco ///s'est rendu
- On leur a donné le week-end
pour lui dire adie
Quelques jours
pour l'immortaliser,
pour le déco c c c c c c c c c .
C'est comme si toute la ville
degagagavpils, en Lettonie,
située à 30 km de la Russie,
était en deuil.
d'un enterrement au pied
de ce monument érigé à la gloire
des soldats soviétiques.
Larissa sait très bien que
c'est la toute dernière fois
et elle est inconsolable.
"Tous les 9 mai, je viens
déposer des fleurs ici
pour le jour de la Victoire.
Et ce que le gouvernement
le coeur.C'est du vandalisme,
comprenez? Rien de moinsquququq"
Si pour elle et tantesesesesest
le symbole de la libérat
de la victoire de l'Armée rouge,
pour la majorité, etetettonie,
l'emblème de l'occupationvivivii
la Deuxième Ge e e mondiale.
Et l'invasion de l'Ukraineaurat
eu raiso l l leur destin.
(applaudissements)rtrtrtrtrtrtre
pa P P Parlement letton,
tous les monuments qui
(applaudissements)
En vertu de la loi adoptée
par le Parlement letton,
tous les monuments qui
glorifient le régime autoritaire
qu'était celui de l'URSS doivenc
d'ici la mi-novembre.
Les unes après les autres,
les villes s'en débarrassent.
La démolition du monumlalalalale
Riga, au mois d'août, aura été
lululus spectaculaire de toutes.
Et ce, malgré l'opposition
de la minorité russophone
et qui partage une vision
bien différente de l'hiririre.
(chants)
(pleurs)
de 90 % des
d'origine russe, on appréhendait
une telle scène. La mairie
a doenenenenenenenenenenenenene.
Mais pour Julia, ce soir
est un supplice.
Les émotions oscillent
entre la douleur et la colère.
"C'est l'équivalent de nous
crache
Ce monument es s s souvenir.
Il n'a rien à voir avec
un soutien pour la Russie. l l a
beaucoup trop loin."rsrsrsrsrsrs
pour sévir contre toute personne
qui oserait afficher
ses couleurs, comme cette dame,
il est écrit "Russie".
"Je ne suis pas pour la Russie
ni contre l'Ukraine, je suis
po
Quelques minutes plus tard,
elle était ret d d de la foule
de force.
Les lois, en Lettonie,tetetete,
depuis le début de la guerre,
qu'aucun symbole de soutien,
pas seulement à la guerre,
n'est pas toléré. Et donc,
on a demandé à cette femme
d'enlever son manteau
outrée.
"C'est absurdomomomplètement
absurde", dit-elle, alors
qu'on commence à retirerrsrsrsre
au démantèlement.
(chants)
Au son des chants patriotiques
de la Grande Gue q q qui eux
aussi ne sont pas tolérés
ce soir : les policiers
hahahahahahahahahahahahahahahah)
au chevet de leur statue jusqu'à
D'autres sont restés
ce que les bulldozers arrivent
aux petites heures du matin. l e
ira au musée ou encore
au dépotoir.
Le monument n'est plus,
mais les tensions demes s s s s.